three two one zero
ignition spacex is ramping up the pace
of rocket launches in order to conquer
the internet from space
the company has launched more than a
thousand satellites to build a network
called starlink
aimed at bringing faster connections to
billions of people
meanwhile china has launched only a few
test satellites
but the country has sent what it calls
the world's first 6g
satellite which it says would provide
faster service than what's available on
earth
satellite internet is really seen to be
you know an extension of a lot of
the terrestrial internet services the
satellite internet market is expected to
be worth more than 400 billion dollars
by 2040.
the world seems to have an insatiable
appetite for bandwidth
and this competition is taking place in
an area known as low earth orbit
it's first come first serve so they are
racing to
occupy those orbital slots because the
ones that get there first
with the capability of presence is going
to be able to set the rules
and that comes with privacy and security
concerns still
spacex is moving ahead with a larger
fleet of satellites
while the relative newcomer china is
betting on faster speeds to build a
powerful internet network in space
[Music]
satellite-based internet is actually not
new since the mid-1990s people who live
in remote areas and don't have access to
cell towers
have relied on satellites these
satellites are in orbit about 22 000
miles away from earth
and a result of that distance is slow
speed because china's satellites and the
starlink network are closer to earth
that means they can provide much faster
services spacex is currently promising
its beta test customers in the u.s
speeds between 50 and 150 megabits per
second
that's still below the country's average
broadband service on the ground
china has not rolled out its service yet
or demonstrated how its satellite works
but the university that developed the 6g
satellite says it could offer speeds
that can potentially reach at least one
terabyte per second
that means if you download a one
gigabyte movie with starlink service it
would take about 10 seconds
but with the 6g speed that china
promises you could download about a
thousand movies in just one second
china says its 6g plan is an extension
of its 5g network which has already been
rolled out in many chinese cities
this technological progression is
starting to help transform the country's
economy
if you have 6g your ability to have
automation is going to improve
exponentially we mean better
manufacturing
we mean better 3d printing we mean
better self-driving cars
namrata goswami is an independent
researcher who's been studying global
space policy for more than 20 years
and she says china's 6g satellite
network can make a big impact once it's
up and running
once you become the first country to do
it you set the global standards you set
the rules
in terms of how this is going to be
regulated those who are first there
will be able to standardize the
procedures of that particular market and
then you also set the innovation cycle
in technology but spacex has an edge
over china in another way
has a big advantage of having been the
first mover therese jones is a senior
policy director at the satellite
industry association
and she's been studying satellite
communication for seven years
the washington dc-based group represents
over 50 satellite companies in the u.s
including spacex the number is
absolutely a comparative advantage right
now it takes a long time to ramp up
the capabilities to even get 1500
satellites on orbit
and just ramp up your satellite
manufacturing capabilities to
reach that point that's because spacex
runs its own supply chain to produce the
satellites and handles everything else
from launching to operating them
it's taken the company three years to
plot a constellation of more than a
thousand satellites planning to
eventually deploy a total of twelve
thousand
spacex has the goal of you know
providing ubiquitous connectivity
across the globe um whether that is
providing internet to rural areas
whether it's providing
uh you know internet to ships to planes
and that global plan could help more
than three billion people in the world
who don't have regular access to the
internet
we'll serve the hardest to serve
customers
after an installation cost of about 600
the monthly fee to use starling
satellites would be about 100
spacex says it's already received 500
000 pre-orders for its service
and the company's plans for expansion
could get a boost from the us government
as it recently won preliminary rights to
nearly 900 million dollars in subsidies
but spacex's bid for funds and its
prolific launches have started to draw
criticism from rivals in the u.s and
europe
who say starling satellites are crowding
orbit and endangering other satellites
so some are asking regulators to clamp
down on the spacex project
the company didn't respond to a request
for comment china could also face
similar pushback from rivals since it
also plans to launch more than 10 000
satellites
but this mega plan has one strong ally
the one advantage that the country has
is that it has one party
so the support is very much consistent
it's very clear
china's goal under president xi has been
to become a leader in innovation
and technology and especially
communications technology
but big networks of satellites also
generate a lot of personal data
there are these concerns that your data
can be turned over it could be used for
espionage
intelligence operations it could be used
to have economic advantage
because you can also spy into their
economic system
for example us officials have long said
beijing could direct chinese telecom
companies like huawei which have set up
5g networks abroad
to spy or sabotage huawei and the
chinese government have rejected the
charges
but goswami says china's 6g network
could open up similar concerns
chinese law makes it mandatory for any
company or citizen to collaborate with
chinese intelligence
in case such a request is made but in
the u.s the legal system could provide a
level of protection
spacex cannot turn over data just
because u.s intelligence will want it
you will have to go to court
to get permission spacex didn't respond
to a request for comment
while china's foreign ministry said that
chinese law protects data security and
personal information of citizens and
organizations
for now spacex is moving ahead by
seeking permission for another 30
000 satellites but china's network could
have one more advantage when it's ready
china can always make it mandatory for
its citizens to have
that kind of service in its devices
making the world's most populated
country a place to continue testing the
service
and honing the technology